-Joining us right now is the
host of "The Reidout" on MSNBC,
which airs weekdays at 7:00 p.m.
Please welcome Joy Reid!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Joy!
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
I always love it
when you come on the show.
Today we learned the verdict
of the trial.
Derek Chauvin was found guilty
on all three charges.
Can you explain, like --
walk us through the charges
and what they mean?
-Absolutely. Well, first of all,
thank you, Jimmy.
It's always great
to be on with you.
So, basically, Derek Chauvin
faced second-degree murder,
third-degree murder,
and manslaughter charges.
And those sentences potentially
go all the way from about --
almost 50 years
for second-degree murder,
which is intentional murder,
down to manslaughter,
which is basically sort of
enhanced negligence,
just behaving negligently
in a way that caused death.
He got them all.
He was found guilty
on all three.
And I can tell you, Jimmy, the
time that it became pretty clear
to me that he was likely to be
convicted is when we heard
there was a verdict and the jury
had only been out for 11 hours.
And that's about the time
that the Mohamed Noor jury,
which was another
police officer,
a black police officer
in Minneapolis
who was convicted of
second-degree murder --
they were out
for about 11 hours.
So a very quick return
of a verdict
kind of indicated that it was
going to be guilty.
-Yeah. I mean,
I don't know what it was like
for you in the studio.
But for me, I'm just
shaking the whole day.
And I go, "Well, I've seen
the craziest stuff happen,"
for a second, and you go --
I mean, were you at all going,
"I wouldn't be surprised if..."
-I have to tell you, Jimmy,
I'm very, very cynical about
charges against police.
Right? You can go all the way
back to Amadou Diallo,
who was shot
in his own vestibule.
And this was, I think, in 1999.
An African immigrant shot dead
by the police.
No charges.
You can go to Patrick Dorismond,
who was killed in New York
around that same period
where Rudolph Giuliani,
when he was mayor,
released his juvenile record
to justify him being killed by
an undercover police officer.
Go all the way through --
Walter Scott,
the case where you saw a man
running in South Carolina
from a police officer,
and he shoots him dead,
shoots him in the back.
That jury hung,
and it was on tape as well.
You can just go through it.
Michael Brown.
You can go through Tamir Rice,
who was a 12-year-old child
playing with a toy gun.
Police officer jumps out,
shoots him immediately.
No charges.
So I tend to go with
the statistics that show --
what? -- about 2% of
police officers
are ever convicted
of killing someone,
let alone killing
somebody black.
So I tend to think, when
a police officer is charged,
I steel myself for them
to not be charged.
And then if they're charged,
I steel myself emotionally
for them to be acquitted,
'cause that's normally
what happens.
So the fact that this was
such a lopsided case,
watching it every day,
the quality of the prosecution
versus the sort of phoned-in,
strange quality of the defense,
even that doesn't guarantee
a conviction when it's police.
-Right.
-But the fact that I think
you had 10 police officers,
including the police chief,
testify against this officer,
which I've never seen,
the fact you had so much
unanimity of police experts
testifying against
this police officer,
it did feel like the momentum
was going in
the prosecution's direction.
But I didn't dare assume
that that was going to
be the outcome.
-Right.
It's hard to imagine
what the family of George Floyd
is going through right now,
obviously.
But there's got to be
some feeling
that there's been justice.
-Absolutely. This is so rare.
I mean, again, Jimmy,
think about how rare it is
for a police officer
to be convicted of
killing a black man, woman,
or child in America.
For this family,
they have achieved something
almost revolutionary.
They have not only been able
to get justice for themselves,
which isn't going to
ease their pain.
They don't have their brother,
their family member,
their loved one.
He's gone.
But they've achieved justice
that is going to radiate
potentially
throughout our system,
because the defense that was
put on for Derek Chauvin
was the same defense that was
put on in the Rodney King case.
"He had super-human strength.
He was on drugs, therefore
he was going to get up,
really rise from the dead,"
'cause he was dead
for about three minutes
of Derek Chauvin having his knee
and his full body weight on him,
that he was going to rise from
the dead and still be a threat.
"The black man
is always a threat.
The black body is a threat."
He tried everything.
"He was on drugs.
He was, you know, the real
culprit in his own death."
And that didn't work.
And so I think what's happened
is that we've established
a line that was drawn by police,
a line that was drawn
in the criminal justice system,
that you just can't kill a man
in front of witnesses,
including a 9-year-old, on video
camera and walk away from it.
I think it's important
that we draw that line
because law enforcement
is losing the consent
of the governed.
They're losing credibility with
the American people,
particularly in communities
of color.
This needed to go this way,
in a way, just for our society
to be able to take
a step forward.
-I thought it was interesting,
too, after the verdict
was announced, seeing different
locations and people's reaction.
It wasn't so much -- It wasn't
celebration or people jumping.
It was just people going...
and just taking a beat.
And that was like, wow.
That was powerful.
-Yeah, there's nothing
to celebrate
when someone goes to prison,
right?
This man's life is over --
Derek Chauvin.
He made a decision, and he had
9 minutes and 29 seconds
to change his mind
and make a different choice.
The decision he made
is the end of his career.
It's the end, maybe,
of his freedom
for the rest of his life.
We don't know what kind of
a sentence he's going to get.
He has tainted law enforcement.
He has embarrassed
and shamed his department.
And that was what
the testimony was,
that this was an embarrassment
to what law enforcement
is supposed to be.
Law enforcement people
that I know
were embarrassed by what he did.
He shamed himself
and he's lost his freedom.
There's nothing to celebrate.
But I do think that for
the family it's a relief, right?
I mean, there were people
who were interviewed by
Shaq Brewster, who's
our reporter on the ground,
who said, "I can breathe now."
People can stop
holding their breath.
And I think just for a moment
we can acknowledge
that that is -- it is a relief.
It isn't anything
to be joyful about.
-Joy, thank you so much
for coming on to speak to us.
I always appreciate it.
Joy Reid, everyone.